***
Sie kann singen.
*Gesang*
Sie kann tanzen.
*fröhliche Musik*
Vor allem kann sie fliegen.
Und das nur mit einem Regenschirm.
*Musik*
Mary Poppins,
practically perfect in every way.
Warum ihr Flug in der Realität
nicht so galant aussähe wie im Film
und was sie daran ändern könnte,
kläre ich heute
mit meinem Lieblingsphysiker Henry.
♪ Je t'aime.
Wenn wir schon Disney machen,
dann bitte richtig, mit Musik!
*fröhliche Musik*
Hey Susanne,
hast du Lust mitzusingen?
Ja, klar.
♪ Super, denn die Frage ist:
Echt nochmal, wie geht das?
♪ Wir haben keine Ahnung,
aber Henry, der versteht es!
♪ Wollt ihr's wirklich wissen?
♪ Dann freut euch,
denn ihr seht es:
♪ Science vs. Fiction
wird heute explain-aligetisch!
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Nicht nur
mit einer singenden Mathematikerin,
sondern auch
mit einem tanzenden Physiker.
Hey, Henry!
- Hey, Jack!
Lass uns auf das Wissenschaftliche
konzentrieren.
Wir schauen uns diese Szene an.
Die ist fantastisch dargestellt,
sie kommt angeflogen.
Es gibt Leute,
die versuchen das nachzustellen.
Und scheitern dabei kläglich.
Ja, aber wir haben etwas,
das die nicht hatten.
Was?
- Einen Physiker.
*Hip-Hop-Musik*
Du erklärst uns erstmal,
warum das so nicht funktioniert.
Dann lass uns direkt
mit der ikonischen Anfangsszene
aus dem Film starten.
Mary Poppins hat bei Familie Banks
ein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Sie kommt aus luftigen Höhen
galant angeflogen.
Eigentlich schwebt sie rein
und landet soft vor der Haustür.
Ich habe die Zeit gestoppt.
26 Sekunden dauert die Nummer.
Die 26 Sekunden will ich anzweifeln.
Weil, sie fällt ja vom Himmel.
Das stimmt, aber sie hat den Schirm.
Der bremst sie ja auch.
Der würde sie bremsen,
aber es kommt darauf an,
was für ein Schirm es ist.
Das schauen wir uns an.
Ich habe hier einen Disney-Nachbau.
Der hat die gleichen Maße
wie der aus dem Film.
Wir brauchen die Fläche, oder?
- Genau.
Wir brauchen die Querschnittsfläche.
Nehmen wir an, sie wäre ein Kreis.
Du misst den Radius
von der Mitte bis zum Rand.
Das mache ich und das ist fast exakt
ein halber Meter.
O.k., cool.
Ich gebe dir den Schirm zurück.
Die Fläche berechnen wir
mit der Formel aus der Schule.
Pi mal r zum Quadrat.
Mit dem gemessenen Radius
ergibt das ca. 0,8 qm Fläche.
Wenn der Schirm fällt,
üben die Luftmoleküle
eine Kraft auf ihn nach oben aus.
Je größer die Querschnittsfläche,
desto mehr Moleküle sind da.
Desto größer die Kraft,
die auf ihn wirkt.
Man könnte meinen, dass Mary Poppins
immer schneller fällt.
Das ist nicht so.
Denn die wirkende Kraft
hängt ab von der Geschwindigkeit.
Je schneller sie fällt,
desto größer ist die Kraft.
Irgendwann ist sie
genauso groß wie die Kraft,
die sie nach unten zieht,
die Gewichtskraft.
Da gleicht sich das aus.
Irgendwann erreicht Mary
eine Maximalgeschwindigkeit,
die Endgeschwindigkeit.
Ab dieser Geschwindigkeit
kann sie nicht schneller werden.
Mit der fällt sie konstant zu Boden.
Deshalb kann man Menschen
nicht mit einer Münze töten,
die man vom Hochhaus schmeißt.
Die Münze erreicht schon
nach wenigen Metern
ihre Endgeschwindigkeit.
So kann man Leute nicht verletzen.
Lass uns die Endgeschwindigkeit
von Mary ausrechnen.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Man müsste eine
Differenzialgleichung aufstellen.
Die zu lösen, ist nervig.
Das könnte
eine Mathematikerin machen.
Aber Susanne hört gerade nicht zu.
Deshalb
machen wir es wie die Physiker.
Mit einer Näherungslösung.
- Wir bescheißen also?
Wir bescheißen wissenschaftlich.
- Wie geht das?
Wir nehmen an,
dass Mary die ganze Zeit
mit dieser Endgeschwindigkeit fällt.
Weil der Beschleunigungsbereich,
in dem sie
auf die Endgeschwindigkeit kommt,
der ist super kurz.
Den lassen wir weg.
Wir nehmen an, sie fällt
mit konstanter Geschwindigkeit.
Dann können wir zur Berechnung
diese Formel nehmen.
Da stecken verschiedene Sachen drin.
Zum einen die Erdbeschleunigung
mit 9,81 m/s zum Quadrat.
Und die Masse von Mary Poppins.
Das sind ca. 60 kg
mit allem, was sie anhat.
Für den Luftwiderstand
haben wir die Dichte der Luft.
Das sind ca. 1,22 kg/Kubikmeter.
Dazu
kommt der Luftwiderstandsbeiwert.
Das ist ein Wert dafür, wie viel
Widerstand der Schirm bietet.
Das kann man nachschlagen.
Der beträgt etwa 1,5.
Und wir brauchen
die Querschnittsfläche des Schirms.
Alles zusammen ergibt
eine Geschwindigkeit von 28,6 m/s.
Das entspricht ca. 103 km/h.
- What?
100 Sachen, mit denen sie
auf dem Boden aufschlägt.
Das wäre nicht so galant,
wie wir es sehen.
Die wäre Matsch.
- Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist der Grund, weshalb die 26 s
vom Anfang nicht stimmen können.
Würde sie für 26 s
mit diesen 28,6 m/s fallen,
ergäbe sich eine Höhe
für ihren Start von 750 m.
Das sehen wir in der Szene
auf jeden Fall nicht.
Wir können festhalten,
wenn Mary Poppins mit diesem Schirm
vom Himmel kommen würde,
würde sie das leider nicht überleben.
Tut mir leid, Mary.
*dramatische Musik*
♪ Chim-chimmeny,
chim-chimmeny, chim-chim cheree.
♪ Vom Schornstein mit Schirm
ist eine blöde Idee.
♪ Chim-chimmeny,
chim-chimmeny, chim-chim cheruu.
♪ Lass sein, Mary Poppins,
ich spring’ nicht, spring’ du!
♪ Dein Schirmflug,
er ist physikalisch tabu.
So wie im Film klappt es also nicht.
Wir sagten, wir wollen
den Schirmflug möglich machen.
Was bräuchte Mary,
damit die Landung so sanft wird,
wie wir sie sehen?
Erstmal
muss der Schirm stabiler werden.
Was passiert,
wenn du mit einem Schirm
im Sturm unterwegs bist?
Der klappt so nach oben.
- Genau, der klappt weg.
Also muss alles Klappbare
aus der Struktur raus.
Wir müssen die Streben steif machen.
Den Stoff können wir so lassen.
Der ist derselbe wie
bei einem Fallschirm und zwar Nylon.
Er muss aber anders vernäht sein.
Und zwar in dieser Kästchenstruktur.
Dann wird er besonders reißfest.
Der Stoff muss fest
mit dem Streben verbunden sein,
damit er nicht abreißt.
Wir haben Stoff
und Struktur geklärt.
Was noch fehlt,
wir müssen ihn größer machen.
Wir haben für die Formel
die Querschnittsfläche gebraucht.
Wenn sie größer ist,
gibt es mehr Widerstand.
Wie groß müsste der Schirm sein?
Um das auszurechnen,
nehmen wir die Formel von vorhin.
Und stellen sie nach dem Radius um.
Da brauchen wir
eine neue Endgeschwindigkeit,
mit der sie bequem landen kann.
Schauen wir in die Szene.
Sie landet
mit flotter Schrittgeschwindigkeit.
Etwa 7 km/h.
Wenn wir das einsetzen,
kommen wir auf einen Radius von 7 m.
7 m!
14 m im Durchmesser.
Holy shit, das ist viel.
Ich habe etwas gegoogelt.
Die größten Schirme sind
Sonnenschirme mit 5 m Durchmesser.
Aber bei 14 m, da sind wir sogar
über den Militärschirmen drüber.
Die haben etwa 10 m.
Unsere Variante wäre irre groß.
Stimmt, aber rein rechnerisch
könnte sie easy zu Boden schweben.
Aber in der Realität
gibt es noch ein anderes Problem.
Schau mal, wie sie den Schirm hält.
Das ist nicht clever.
Das hatten wir schon
in unserer One-Piece-Folge.
Da musste ich einen Bierkasten
mit ausgestreckten Armen anheben.
Das war sauschwer.
- So ähnlich ist es hier auch.
Denn auf den Schirm wirkt
die Kraft des Luftwiderstands.
Die Kraft wirkt auch
auf ihren ausgestreckten Arm.
Also, bräuchte sie riesige Kraft
in den Rückenmuskeln,
um den Schirm zu halten.
Besser wäre es, sie würde den Schirm
mit beiden Händen am Körper halten.
Dann müsste sie
nur ihr eigenes Gewicht halten.
Genau.
Aber es gibt noch ein 2. Problem.
Am Ende des Films
will sie mit dem Schirm abheben.
Das geht leider absolut nicht.
Erstens müsste sie
den Monsterschirm hochhieven.
Der wäre ziemlich schwer.
Da könnte man sagen,
wir bauen ihn aus
einem leichten Material wie Carbon.
Dann kriegt sie ihn hoch.
Aber da ist das Problem,
dass der Wind
bei normaler Windgeschwindigkeit
parallel zum Boden weht.
Er müsste aber
unter den Schirm drunter gehen.
Das passiert nur bei Orkan.
Das sehen wir
in der Szene überhaupt nicht.
Ganz ehrlich,
das ist auch kein Wetter,
bei dem man
zum Bewerbungsgespräch fliegt.
Absolut nicht.
Wir halten fest,
um so sanft zu landen wie im Film,
müsste Mary einen sehr viel größeren,
sehr viel stabileren Schirm haben.
Um damit abzuheben,
müsste ein Orkan wehen,
damit der Wind im richtigen Winkel
unter dem Schirm kommt.
Genau.
Henry, vielen Dank fürs Erklären.
- Sehr gern.
Wie könnten wir die Folge
besser zu einem Abschluss bringen,
als mit einem letzten Song-Klassiker
von Disney?
*dramatische Musik*
Susanne, hast du Lust
noch einmal mitzusingen?
Oh ja!
♪ Es ist die Wissenschaft,
♪ die uns hier
unseren Kindheitsfilm erklärt.
♪ Tja, denn Disney
lügt uns ins Gesicht.
♪ Aber mit Formel-Algebra,
da sehen wir: AHA!
♪ Das geht ja nicht,
so wie es der Film verspricht.
♪ Wenn ein Löffel voll Science
falsche Filmfakten versüßt,
♪ Filmfakten versüßt,
Filmfakten versüßt.
♪ Wenn ein Löffel voll Science
falsche Filmfakten versüßt,
♪ checkt man es
gleich nochmal so gut.
Das war "Science vs. Fiction"
für heute.
Danke, Henry, fürs Erklären.
Danke, Susanne, fürs Mitsingen.
Wenn ihr Kanäle auschecken wollt,
geht zu den Links in der Infobox.
Vergesst auf keinen Fall,
diesen Kanal zu abonnieren.
Und die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Ich freue mich, tschüss!
Wir halten fest,
Mary Poppins könnte tatsächlich
mit einem richtig stabilen,
riesigen Monsterschirm ...
Was denn?
Stabiler Monsterschirm.
Also halten wir fest,
Mary Poppins könnte tatsächlich
mit einem richtig stabilen
Monsterschirm ...
Noch einmal konzentrieren.
Halten wir fest, Mary Poppins ...
*Lachen*
(Frau) Das ist so absurd.
Aber es ist doch
ein großer Monsterschirm.
Was ist denn?
Ich sage nicht Monsterschirm,
ich sage großer Schirm.
*Lachen*
Oh, Leute, wir haben es doch gleich.
Ich will nach Hause.
*Lachen*
Es wird nix.
Copyright MDR 2023